>> Lawrence: I'M LAWRENCE JONES
IN NEW YORK.
THE HEARING WITH ANTONY BLINKEN
WAS SUPPOSED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF BIDEN'S AWFUL
AFGHANISTAN EVACUATION.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BLINKEN IS A MASTER AT DODGING
QUESTIONS.
WE DIDN'T GET MANY ANSWERS,
HOWEVER, ONE THING DID HAPPEN.
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY WENT OFF
SCRIPT AND AND ASKED SECRETARY
OF STATE ABOUT BIDEN.
>> HOW LONG WAS YOUR RECENT
INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI AND WAS
IT A DEPOSITION?
>> I'M SORRY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE REFERRING.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
NOT HAD A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH
THE FBI SINCE BECOMING SECRETARY
OF STATE?
>> I'M, -- I -- I'M NOT SURE
WHAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THAT UP WITH
YOU OFF LINE.
>> DID THE STATE DEPARTMENT TURN
OVER DOCUMENTS TO THE FBI
RELATED TO HUNTER BIDEN, BURISMA
AND/OR THE BLUE STATE STRATEGIES
CORPORATION?
>> UM, YOU WILL HAVE TO, UM,.
>> SO HAVE YOU NO KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS?
ARE YOU SAYING YOU HAVE NOT HAD
AN INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI SINCE.
>> IT WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR ME TO COMMENT IN A PUBLIC
FORUM ON ANY LEGAL PROCEEDINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
>> I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO COMMENT
ON THE LEGAL PROCEEDINGS.
I'M JUST ASKING IF YOU HAVE BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI SINCE
BECOMING SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> UM, AGAIN, I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMENT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER ON
ANY LEGAL PROCEEDINGS OR NOT
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> LET ME REMIND THE GENTLEMAN
THAT THE TOPIC OF THIS HEARING
IS AFGHANISTAN.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE.
>> I APPRECIATE IT,
MR. CHAIRMAN.
BUT THE SECRETARY GENERALLY
REFUSES TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN SO I JUST
FIGURED WE WOULD TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING HE SHOULD BE
INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH.
HAVE YOU SOUGHT TO ALTER ANY OF
YOUR TESTIMONY FROM LAST YEAR'S
SENATE INVESTIGATION REGARDING
THIS TOPIC?
[GAVEL]
>> THE GENTLEMAN'S TIME IS
EXPIRED.
LAWRENCE LAWRPS THE MAN ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS IS SENATOR SCOTT
PERRY HE IS HERE TO REACT.
CONGRESSMAN, IS VERY CLEAR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WAS CAUGHT
OFF GUARD.
HE WAS STUMBLING.
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING AT RIGHT
THERE?
WHY DID YOU CHOOSE THAT LINE OF
QUESTIONING?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> WELL, LAWRENCE, FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S BETTER TO OFFER NO EXCUSE
THAN A SERIES OF BAD EXCUSES
THAT HEARING CERTAINLY PROVES TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT POOR
EXCUSE FOR SECRETARY OF STATE
AND EVEN WORSE ONE FOR PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID,
LISTEN, WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS -- OBVIOUSLY BLINKEN IS
WELL-COACHED, HE WOULDN'T COME
IN PERSON.
IS HE ON VIDEO SO HE CAN
PRESCRIPT ALL THE QUESTIONS.
WE CAN'T -- YOU KNOW, THE SCREEN
GOES DARK WHEN WE'RE TALKING SO
HE HAS TIME TO SEE OUR QUESTIONS
AND HEAR OUR QUESTIONS AND THEN
GET AN ANSWER FROM HIS ADVISERS
BEFORE HE ACTUALLY ANSWERS.
AND HE WASN'T GOING TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS REALISTICALLY ON
THE HORRIFIC FAILURE OF
AFGHANISTAN SO I THOUGHT I WOULD
TALK TO HIM ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
I KNEW WAS REPORTED THAT HE HAD
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FBI
AND THAT POTENTIALLY THEY HAVE
CALLED HIM BACK IN BECAUSE
SOMETHING IS NOT MATCHING UP
REGARDING HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
HUNTER BIDEN WHEN HE WAS
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF STATE.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OUGHT TO KNOW.
I QUESTIONED THIS SECRETARY OF
STATE'S JUDGMENT AND HIS
CREDIBILITY REGARDING
AFGHANISTAN AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND THE FACT THAT HE HAS HAD A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH HUNTER
BIDEN WHEN HE WAS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF STATE REGARDING
EVENTS IN UKRAINE, THAT'S VERY
CONCERNING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO
KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> Lawrence: I WANT TO SLOW YOU
DOWN FOR A SECOND BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
AUDIENCE TO KNOW.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT YOU KNOW FOR
A FACT THAT HE MET WITH THE FBI
REGARDING HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
HUNTER BIDEN? IT.
AND THAT'S SECRETARY ANTONY
BLINKEN.
>> Lawrence: DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN HUNTER BIDEN AND THE
SECRETARY?
BECAUSE A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY IS HE
CONTACTING THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF STATE?
-- WOULD HE BE ABLE TO DO THAT
IF HE WASN'T JOE BIDEN'S SON?
WHAT IS THE REACH FOR THAT
CONNECTION?
>> WELL, THERE ARE EMAILS OUT
THERE IN OPEN SOURCE THAT SHOW
THE CONVERSATION WAS NOT ABOUT
AS I UNDERSTAND IT WHAT ANTONY
BLINKEN SAID WHICH WAS BO BIDEN.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE ABOUT BO
BIDEN.
I THINK THEY ARE ABOUT ISSUES OF
UKRAINE AND OTHER NAVY PROJECTS
THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING ON
AND THAT'S PER THE EMAILS THAT
ARE OALREADY OUT THERE.
>> Lawrence: ARE YOU SUGGESTING
IT WAS BURISMA?
>> I CAN'T SUGGEST ANYTHING.
I WANT THE SECRETARY OF STATE,
YOU KNOW, HE WANTS TO TALK TO ME
OFFLINE, I SUGGEST THAT HE TALK
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND LET
ALL OF US KNOW WHAT HE WAS
TALKING WITH HUNTER BIDEN ABOUT.
>> Lawrence: HAS HE CALLED YOU,
CONGRESSMAN HE?
TALKED WITH THAT DURING THE
HEARING THAT HE WAS WILLING TO
TALK OFF LINE.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY COORDINATION
BETWEEN YOUR OFFICE TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE SECRETARY TO GET SOME
ANSWERS?
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT TODAY.
>> NO.
HE DID NOT.
YOU COULD TELL BY THE LOOK ON
HIS FACE HE DIDN'T DENY IT,
RIGHT?
BUT YOU HE HASN'T CALLED ME
ABOUT IT.
MAYBE HE IS CALLING YOU,
LAWRENCE, BUT HE HASN'T CALLED
ME ABOUT IT.
>> Lawrence: DO YOU PLAN TO
REACHING BACK TO HIS OFFICE
SINCE HE SAID UNDER OATH TODAY
THAT HE WAS WILLING TO DO THAT?
DO YOU PLAN ON REACHING OUT TO
HIS OFFICE TO GET THOSE ANSWERS?
WE CERTAINLY DO, LAWRENCE.
WE ARE JUST REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PEOPLE.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE THIS INFORMATION.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHETHER THIS GUY
IS CREDIBLE.
WHETHER HIS JUDGMENT IS SOUND.
JUST, REMEMBER, HE JUST
PRESIDED.
HE AND PRESIDENT BIDEN PRESIDED
OVER THE WORST FOREIGN POLICY
AND NATIONAL SECURITY FAILURE IN
UNITED STATES HISTORY.
I THINK THERE IS REACH TO
QUESTION EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN.
>> Lawrence: CONGRESSMAN, WHY
DID YOUR CHAIRMAN CUT YOU OFF IN
THE MIDDLE OF THAT HEARING?
BECAUSE IT SEEMED LIKE WHEN YOU
WERE GETTING TO THE FACTS OF THE
STORY, AND HE STARTED TO SHUFFLE
A LITTLE BIT, THAT THE CHAIRMAN
JUMPED IN.
IS THAT PROCEDURE IN THE HOUSE?
>> WELL, WHAT'S PROCEDURE IS BY
DEMOCRATS AND YOU LOOK THEY ALL
CLOSE RANK NO MATTER HOW
HORRIFIC THE POLICY IS, 13 DEAD
MARINES, AMERICA BEING, YOU
KNOW, OUR REPUTATION BEING
DRAGGED ACROSS THE WORLD STAGE,
THEY ALL CLOSE RANKS AND DO
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE FAILED POLICY AND THEIR
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE POWER THAT
THEY HAVE AND THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO LET ANYBODY ASSAIL THEIR
SECRETARY OF STATE, YOU KNOW, ON
AN OPEN MIKE, SO, YEAH, HE HAD
TO CUT I